so I think leadership is one of the most
misunderstood subjects in business quite
frankly very often when we talk about
leaders we're talking about rank or
hierarchy but you and I both know uh
many people throughout our careers who
had very high levels of companies who
are not leaders
we do as they tell us because they have
authority over us but we would never
trust them or choose to follow them and
you and I both know people at low levels
of organizations who have no formal rank
or authority and yet they've made the
choice to look after the person's left
of them and to look after the person to
the right of them and we trust them and
would follow them anywhere leadership
fundamentally is the responsibility to
see those around us rise and uh we hope
that you you obey and exhibit the
qualities of good leadership when you
have a position of leadership
but you can obey and pursue good
leadership at any rank leadership has
nothing to do with the rank or position
it's the responsibility to see those
around us rise that's what makes someone
a leader one of the big mistakes is to
think that it's all about you
um you know human beings are social
animals
um if we could do everything by
ourselves we wouldn't need friends and
we wouldn't need a team we wouldn't need
co-workers we could just do everything
ourselves and at the end of the day we
can't do everything ourselves
um and so it's understanding that you're
a part of a machine and and the more you
help keep that machine well oiled which
means open and clear communication uh
setting uh clear guidelines and
expectations
um being able to resolve conflict uh in
a healthy manner
um things like this help keep the
machine working and that the people who
support you uh will be there for you
because they know that you would be
there for them
um and so what great leaders do is they
they they work to be there for their
team members or those uh in in in in
their care
um remember when we're Junior
uh in our companies when we first you
know joined the company
um the company will give us tons and
tons of training
so that we'll be good at our jobs right
and some people get Advanced degrees
engineers and the like we'll get
Advanced degrees so that they'll be good
at their job and if you're really good
at your job eventually you'll get
promoted to a position where you're now
responsible for the people who do the
job you used to do
but we very rarely give any kind of
training or uh uh uh sort of
apprenticeship on how to be a leader and
just because somebody was good at their
job doesn't mean they're good at leading
other people's being that good at that
job you know a good sales person doesn't
necessarily make a good sales manager
for example they're different skill sets
um and so one of the things we have to
remember when we when we occupy a
position of leadership is we now have
the responsibility to see those in our
team to see those on our team do well to
help them work to their natural best
it's not just about us and how good we
are or how good we were when we used to
do the job they used to it's a different
skill set and a different mindset